hey mike how are you morgan i'm good
this show is hot so steamy
i want to know your reaction when you
first read the script
yikes um i mean my initial reaction
was can we really film this um after we
film it can we
show it yes
because in the writing you can be a lot
more graphic than how we've
shot it and we've shot it pretty graphic
so
um and then you throw in the added
curveball of filming a show like this in
the age of
covid we started filming the first three
weeks prior to the world shutting down
and then it really
posed the question can we film a show
like this
in this environment and that's a
testament to the cast and to these
the creative team and to the amazing
crew we had in toronto
in making everything work we were one of
the first shows back in toronto
on a show like this so i feel pretty
pretty fortunate
i love that you know this show is
directed by women it's mostly written by
women it's definitely driven from the
female perspective was that refreshing
for you to read
that perspective a hundred percent um
i think it's different as a guy it's so
many questions we've gotten of
how do you feel being a man under the
female gaze and i think as men
there's well for me and adam i think i
can speak to uh we kind of look at that
and say
yeah use me i don't know excuse me um
but i have i i have two daughters myself
and it's an important to give
voice to uh to female desire
and passion and questions of
of how do i balance the things as
as a woman uh that you'll go through
over the course of a long relationship
and motherhood and all of those things
all which i'm
wholly unqualified to speak to but that
something gives a voice to them
is important to me yeah well it's on
social media that you celebrated your
18th wedding anniversary earlier this
year
that's right yep that is wild uh what
does your wife think of this series
she's not seen it yet um she's not seen
it yet but it was
it was important to her that we tell
this story i gave her
i gave her the kill switch she read all
the episodes along with me before we
even started filming
and uh again we have we have two
daughters that this was important
that this story goes through and in
watching how she has
incredibly juggled motherhood and
running a business and being a wife and
and somehow balancing the world on the
tip of her finger
uh to ask these questions and to service
these questions was important
so yeah you know no matter how
comfortable
you feel on set sex scenes are awkward
you definitely have your fair share not
as much as sarah and adam
were you relieved you didn't have as
many as them
um yeah
sarah is an absolute champion
for what she had to balance the emotion
with the physicality
um and also
the the the intimate scenes that her and
i had were wholly different
from the scenes that uh that her and
adam had in
in a way the things that we're
experiencing
i am it's being informed by her journal
that i have
sort of delved into and that i'm i'm
trying to replicate oh this is this must
be what she wants because as guys where
we can get kind of on the nose and go oh
this is what she's saying so it must be
that
you know and then just failing miserably
at times and i actually love that i love
not getting it right and the clunkiness
of things because it's
never as smooth as you imagine it being
uh and uh so yeah that was fun
well i'm a big fan of cooper i love this
show so much
and i have like 20 seconds but seeing as
how you've been in relation for so long
so amazing what's the key to a lasting
relationship
i had someone tell me years ago uh
gentlemen
don't stop dating your wives uh when you
do
it's over and so that's something that's
always stuck with me of being attentive
to
laziness is gonna come complacency is
going to come
but don't stop dating your spouse
that is great advice so nice getting to
talk to you
there we go thanks morgan i appreciate
it thanks